okay today I'm going to talk to you
about Sankey diagrams now all a Sankey
diagram is it's a way of showing the
energy efficiency when we have an energy
transfer taking place so the example
we're going to do is just imagine we
have this light bulb so here's this
light bulb and it's obviously giving out
light like that
now let's say I put I supplied this
light bulb with a hundred joules of
energy now not a hundred percent of that
is going to be converted to light
because nothing no device is a hundred
percent efficient there's always going
to be some kind of wasted energy so
let's imagine 20 joules of this was
given out as light but eighty jaw's was
lost to the thermal store so we could
see that this this isn't very
energy-efficient how all of Sankey
diagram does and operates is just a show
to show this in a visual way just to
show this as a diagram now the thing
that I always start off with the Sankey
diagram is my input energy the amount of
energy I put into the device in this
case it was 100 joules
now when you do this you'd normally have
graph paper but graph paper doesn't show
up very well on the camera so I'm just
going to use this plain paper here so
I've got to think of a decent scale
because if I'm going to show 100
obviously I haven't got 100 centimetres
on this ruler so I'm gonna have to think
of a good scale so what I'm actually
going to do is one centimeter on my
Sankey diagram is going to represent 10
joules so then when I draw my line here
it's gonna be 10 centimeters long that's
10 20 30 40 50 60 70 80 90 100 joules so
I've started with my input energy okay
now the thing with the Sankey diagram is
it really doesn't matter how far the
arrows go it's all just about the width
of them so all I'm going to do is I'm
just gonna draw maybe about 10
centimeters top and bottom and you'll
see why in a minute it really doesn't
matter how far these go as long as
they're level with each other at this
point okay now at this point here they
are going to branch off are useful
energy is
that way and a wasted energies gonna
droop down so for my useful energy my
light that's the thing I actually want
out of my device is 20 joules and each
centimeter is 10 doors the thickness of
this line is going to be 2 centimeters
so this is the bit that's important the
thickness of that that is 2 centimeters
which represents 20 joules I'm then
going to draw that going forwards a bit
again the length does not matter I'm not
even bothering to measure it my ruler
the length does not matter here it's
only the width of matters so that is my
useful energy that is my 20 jaws of
light now the 80 jaws I'm not I don't
want that thermal energy or not that's
not something that I'm desired from this
light bulb so I'm going to draw this
drooping down now because it's 80 joules
it should be 8 centimeters wide so there
we have it now this is how we do it so
from this point we should do the arrow
that's going to come down like this and
split like that so can we see they they
branched off at the same point but apart
from that it doesn't really matter the
useful one usually or nearly always goes
that way and the wasted one droops down
like this so wasted one is eighty jaws
thermal thermal store so we can see it's
all about the thickness of the arrows at
the point at which they branch off from
each other so here I have my hundred
jaws that's my input then 20 jaws is
converted to light which is my useful
energy that's why it's going that way
80 jaws can lost them that were wasted
to the thermal store so it goes down
like this and that's basically how to do
a Sankey diagram thank you